precios por las nubes esto es lo que
encuentran los brasileños más
vulnerables al ir a comprar alimentos en
el mercado de sao paulo
siempre estoy arruinadas siempre
'números rojos' realmente tenemos que
esforzarnos tenemos que ser creativos
para comer y poder comer en agosto la
inflación alcanzó su nivel más alto
desde el año 2000 los precios al
consumidor se dispararon 9,68 entre
agosto de 2020 y agosto de 2021 según
datos del instituto brasileño de
geografía y estadística los alimentos
acumularon todavía más casi 14 por
ciento en ese período
la inflación ha provocado algunos
cambios en el consumo de alimentos en mi
casa estoy reemplazando parte de la
carne roja por frijoles blancos huevos
también veo una gran diferencia en la
factura de la luz debido a esta
inflación
según estimaciones de la fundación
getúlio vargas inmóvil de este año 27 7
millones de brasileños estaban por
debajo del umbral de la pobreza en 2019
la cifra era de 23,1 millones el 23 de
septiembre miembros del movimiento de
trabajadores sin techo invadieron las
instalaciones de la bolsa de sao paulo
para protestar contra la inequidad
social y las políticas del presidente ya
ir bolsonaro
parte de estos aumentos de precios se
puede explicar por un tema externo que
es el tema del mercado de commodities el
mercado cambiario que afecta a los
insumos los costos de producción
otra de las causas es el aumento del
precio de los combustibles que impactó
el transporte además la que es
considerada como la peor sequía en un
siglo ha impactado también el costo de
los alimentos los analistas dicen que el
incremento del costo de vida se
mantendrá al menos hasta 2023 mientras
los brasileños tendrán que seguir
echando mano de su creatividad para
poder subsistir